how do you think President Trump is
doing it's very excellent why he's one
of the first candidates that's actually
going through all of his platform and
policies and actually executing them he
the whole promises made promises cap
desica how do you think the president's
doing I'm slowly disappointed I was
willing to go into it believing that he
would maybe pursue some more responsible
fiscal policies for example but instead
we're getting basically a trade war
because of them putting tariffs and tax
reform was a little bit disappointing
immigration I feels more rhetoric than
actual substantial reform so I would
like to see more steps towards what some
of his original promises that it
could've gotten behind Lauren how's the
president doing I honestly still feel
like I'm living in the twilight zone
that Donald Trump is our president the
extreme lack of accountability the
disrespect is very upsetting to me and I
could speak as an african-american woman
his just all over bigotry I seen only
attack on African Americans and their
intelligence over and over again it's
just extremely disturbing to me and
upsetting Melissa I mean how much time
do you have because I just I remember
waking up the morning of the 2016
elections just like bawling in tears I
think he is racist he is a sexual
predator he just tweets way too much as
the president of the United States I
think he's a liar as well do you believe
in the idea of fake news yes absolutely
I do what what is the fake news I mean
he they they call everyone that supports
him bigots the basket of deplorable the
basket of media's yeah there's a we're
talking about fake news against the
backdrop of the US intelligence agencies
and some officials in the Trump
administration saying Russia is actively
working to undermine democratic
elections in the United States who here
is worried about that
just one person why aren't you worried
about it two people sorry sorry I mean I
guess it is a worry but at this point in
time for me it's what can be done about
it so it's kind of discouraging at this
point where you see that there's an
issue and no one's working to truly
address it and it goes back to the whole
idea of accountability nobody is being
held accountable for anything that's
happening so myself I'm starting to get
discouraged in the political process I
mean I still will go to the polls to
vote however I see change more so on a
local level than nationally but I'm
going to still continue to forge forward
but it's it's pretty discouraging